you hit a degree of stardom or success
in wcw
uh and then you had another stop in one
of like the bigger indies
and then you showed up in wwe and i
remember this as a kid
you showed up as mankind there were
these vignettes they had you
feuding with top stars really like i
think it was undertaker
um or someone pretty elevated
immediately it was undertaker yeah
yeah so i i was watching this and being
like so i'll tell you what i thought as
a kid i'd be like holy [ __ ] cactus jack
is now
with the undertaker so so that you know
this gets interesting
that must have felt like hitting the big
time as like a
wrestler coming up and you went through
a freaking grind to get there i mean you
went through a lot of indies
like a lot of wear and tear so what was
it like when you were premiering in the
wwe
uh which must have been a culmination of
a childhood dream at that point
it was pretty terrifying you know what
maybe for the sake of your
viewers i will show them what mankind
look like all right
it's a mankind character now this the
mask wasn't
a an amazing something you could order
on amazon it was a
leather mask and my hair was long at
that time
kind of wild and so you know and it was
this character where
i realized that by only shielding you
know by obscuring part of my face i
could make
facial expressions work for me with
sideward glances and things like that
and it also prevented people from
really seeing deep down into my eyes
which
you know they say they're the window to
the soul so i would say was about every
six months especially because i was
clearly putting my body on the line
and when wwe came out and announced that
wrestling was entertainment not
competition a lot of people thought it
was going to be the death knell for the
business but now
especially with the success of uh ufc
and mma in general
had we continued to promote what we did
as being the real deal
and then people saw that you can't do an
irish whip like you've never seen an
irish whip
into the octagon or or an elbow drop or
any of those things
but by uh allowing people to appreciate
it for what it was instead of knocking
it for what it was not
people could see all right this guy's
really putting his body on the line for
our entertainment
and then there was almost this like
telltale moment usually six months in
where
they would see through or past
the character and be like i think he's a
nice guy
and and so it was hard to deny
when i was doing so many things for
people's entertainment
that i really cared about what i did and
that i think people drew the conclusion
that i was a nice guy
and that mankind with that mask andrew
would allowed me at first i
i i i disliked it immensely to the point
where
even was this a character that wwe said
hey you're going to show up and hear
here's a mask here's like
this is what happened you know uh i went
to visit mr mcmahon
and he had this um illustration
of a character with a mask that looked
more like leonardo dicaprio in the man
in the iron mask
and what happened uh a year or so
earlier the undertaker
suffered a fractured orbital bone in a
match
and instead of just taking time off like
a normal human being would he wanted to
continue wrestling but they needed
something to protect that bone
they came up with a bunch of drawings
and one of them that was not
used but that mr mcmahon liked was the
template for what
would later become the mankind mask so
he had this idea in his head
of a map we had an idea on paper of a
mask
and jim ross who was the uh president
or executive in charge of talent
relations
had been you know steadily trumpeting me
as a potential
talent but vince mcmahon did not see me
as looking like a star
so bruce pritchard told me this story
only about six or seven years ago or had
i known it
in 1995 when i first first met with mr
mcmahon
my feelings would have been heard he
said that you know my name came up
and then vince he slammed his hand down
on the table said
all right damn it i'll bring him in but
i'm covering up his face
and that was how i gained that was how i
gained my entry into wwe
but i have to believe that undertaker
got on board
and saw me he knew me from wcw in 1990
and followed my career
and felt like although i was not as tall
and not nearly as tall or big as him
that
we could have a great uh a feud based on
like psychological warfare
and so uh without the undertaker again
you and i are not having this
conversation
yeah so you have this legendary feud
with the undertaker
um with that results in this helena cell
match where you get thrown
off the top of the cage and it's a
legitimate
like three-story drop or something where
like
watching it it was 16 feet you know like
people had 40 50 pages my goodness and
it might as well have been 40 or 50 feet
when i was up there looking down
because the people genuinely look like
ants down below i couldn't believe
uh you know i was terrified i was really
terrified and i
i told mr mcmahon that i've been up
there in the afternoon i was comfortable
but the truth is i've never gone up
there
and while i was looking down the
undertaker's music hit
and i know that every eyeball in the
place could be is going to be on him
i looked over the top oh man and andrew
i
rarely curse in real life but uh i think
in curses
and all i was thinking was you got to be
blank and
kidding me there's no blanking way and
the entire time
he was making his way to the ring i was
thinking how can i
climb down this cell without destroying
my career
and i couldn't think of how to do that
so i just stayed up there and hoped for
the best
so you wind up uh taking this incredible
bump off of the top of the cell you land
on a table
and then there is this now iconic image
of you and it seems like a tooth is
somehow like gone through your
your lip but it looks like you're
smiling
uh and and that really emblazoned itself
in the minds of a lot of wrestling fans
you're like this person
is so committed that it seems like
there's some kind of like dental surgery
on offer and they seem to be enjoying it
at least that that was the impression
that you know can i take you behind the
scenes as to what i was actually pleased
before
uh i mean i was out of it it was only
about uh
two years ago that i saw the undertaker
we were doing an appearance together
in the united kingdom and i said how did
i
manage to let you know that i thought i
could continue
because he leaned over and there's a
saying in
in wwe n and wrestling go home means you
know
this is go to the finish and he just
said go home
and under any normal circumstance i
would have thought that
i would have first of all followed
whatever the undertaker said
but on that one night i don't know
something made me feel like i was
capable of continuing
and he said i just kind of mumbled like
i'm okay i'm gonna come out
okay and so he went old school you might
know what that means the undertaker's
six foot 10
320 pounds or maybe around there he may
have been
high 200s 290 295 because
we do exaggerate a little bit he was
probably six eight 290 in
real life but a massive man and he took
me by the wrist he started walking
across the top rope and usually comes
off with a big forearm
and as i mentioned i was limited
physically but i usually really played
it up i'd be wildly thrashing you know
with my arms and body
motion and that video just shows me like
just like a big
sloth just standing there but i knocked
him off the top rope and when he went
down
and sold as we say in the trade like the
uh like the cobwebs started disappearing
dissipating and i started getting a grip
on where i was and i realized that you
know what happened he choked send me
through the cell
neither one of us thought that the cell
was going to give way
like it did and so i crashed through and
i was knocked unconscious
and there was a now this is where we
know medical modern science and what
we've learned about
concussions if that were to happen in
the modern day wwe they just stopped the
match
and that's the right move but
unfortunately in a weird way that was
not the move
that day um because we had this
incredibly surreal uh experience
where we're trying to piece together a
match
when one of the participants is no
longer conscious
and so there was this whole world that
went on during the 42 seconds i was out
so you're saying that
uh that neither of you knew that the
cell was going to give i thought you
were just supposed to be at the top of
that
you thought it was going to gradually
tear so that the the last thing i said
to him before we went out to the ring
was
you might have to choke slam me five or
six times before this thing starts to
give
and instead i went through that thing
like a knife through butter too
and the chair that i brought up on top
of that structure
followed me down hit me in the face so
that as i said
i i collapsed i i the cobwebs started to
dissipate and i was kind of like
sitting against the the bottom and
second turnbuckles
and i realized i had this big wound
underneath my lip
and i just thought to myself you know if
you could find a way to
take your tongue and stick it through
that massive wound
and wriggle it this is terrible like
even then i was like oh that's going to
make for some captivating tv
but as it turned out with the beard and
the blood and the wound wasn't as big as
i thought you couldn't see
my tongue at all but it looked like i
was smiling
uh uh yeah and jim ross said look at
that he's smiling and it really became
this indelible
image it really was yeah yeah but you
know you're like concerned about the
human being's well-being and then it
looked like you were smiling and be like
i guess he's all right
what was you know what was the sense of
things
[Music]
you